nearly six months after Hurricane
Michael slammed into the Florida
Panhandle many people living there are
still trying to put their lives back
together the category four storm made
landfall last October killing 43 people
it caused more than six billion dollars
of damage Manuel Bojorquez is in Panama
City Florida with a look at the
painstaking recovery effort man well
good morning good morning just take a
look around and you can see parts of the
Panhandle look like the hurricane hit
just yesterday some have not been able
to start the cleanup others have simply
left and with an estimated 40,000 homes
either damaged or destroyed the most
critical need here is housing this is
our sub-teams
chilly summers isn't just cooking for
her family she feeds 17 men women and
children who live here a tent city in
her backyard for those who have nowhere
else to go what did you feel when you
saw that there were people that did not
have even a place to set up a tent they
lost their homes and they needed a sense
of security and a sense of belonging
that was the biggest thing for me I mean
she opened up her home to totally still
total strangers the hurricane left Lori
Hogan and her husband Geno homeless they
were staying in a hotel for a little
while but when the money finally ran out
they found a new shelter in Somers
backyard those are tears of gratitude as
tears of gratitude happy we don't know
where we'd be 20 miles away at
Springfield Community Church hundreds of
families still show up for food boxes
grateful but many are frustrated by the
pace of recovery pretty much sickening
you know it's just sickening how they're
putting things first before they put
people first pastor Eddie Pitts who is
displaced himself organized these
volunteers who serve some 12 to 14
hundred people every week there's still
a need here and in their eyes
you talk to them in their eyes they have
been forgotten and they were paying you
that government assistance has arrived
FEMA says nearly 140 million dollars has
been approved the majority of it to be
spent on housing for more than 20,000
people including 820 families in
temporary government housing like Lyman
Wilson and Kelly holliman's family they
moved into temporary FEMA trailers this
week they want to have their own
apartment but rents have skyrocketed
they say the price of the sort of
apartment they had before the storm has
nearly tripled it's impossible yeah just
because Panama City's mayor says there's
little the city can do to control rents
I understand we had 2700 units that were
that were destroyed or or not able to be
lived in less supply price goes up
driving around the scars of Hurricane
Michael are everywhere especially in
Mexico Beach where it made landfall
that's where we found Bella and Jack
Sebastian sitting among the demolition
crews and abandoned slabs they are
living in a FEMA trailer on the spot
where their three-story beachside
retirement home was ripped apart by
Michael but they're not giving up on
their dream in a place where the natural
beauty helps sustain them this is where
you doesn't matter if it's seen that car
is in a van in a tent in a trailer in a
house it doesn't matter there's never
been an option for us Mexico Beach is
home and unless the federal government
extends the disaster declaration here
FEMA housing will run out at the end of
April next year but the sebastien say
like so many others rebuilding their
home will take considerably longer David
many I look at that backdrop behind you
you know we owe those people a faster
response by the way that looks like the
storm hit last week really glad you're
there Manny thank you